das hier sind keine normalen Pancakes
sondern Bananen Pancakes aus überreifen
Bananen und irgendwie haben die einen
besonderen Platz in meinem Herzen
probieren wir geil zunächst einmal
schälen wir unsere Bananen und dann
geben wir sie einfach in eine Schüssel
dann nehmen wir uns eine Gabel und
zermatschen sie einfach so sollte das
ganze aussehen dann geben wir unsere
Eier dazu pro Banane ein Ei zwei Bananen
zwei Eier und wir verquöen das ganze
jetzt geben wir meh rein bis wir die
gewünschte Konsistenz erreicht haben das
Beste daran ist ihr können statt Mehl
auch Proteinpulver benutzen wenn ihr
irgendwie bisschen mehr Eiweiß drin
haben wollt das ist die perfekte
Konsistenz und jetzt könnt ihr
reinmachen worauf ihr Lust habt sei es
Zimt seines schokochips es passt
wirklich viel gut dazu ich habe jetzt
weiße Schokolade und backen wir die
Dinger oder Butter in die Pfanne wie bei
allen Pancakes mittlere Hitze so dass
sie schön Zeit haben zum durchbacken und
jetzt einfach die Pancakes ausbacken ich
finde man sieht ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
mal dass es bananenpancakes sind es
können auch ganz normale sein und wenn
die Pancakes fertig sind wenden wir Sie
und fertig sind unsere Pancakes und wir
haben einen wunderschönen bananenpancak
Stapel die Pancakes könnt ihr jetzt nach
Belieben toppen